congratulations on your new book and
it's finally out but how does it feel
knowing that
the world now has this intimate look
inside of your life i'm very excited and
ready i've been working on this for a
long time it's finally people are
finally able to read it and digest it
and i'm excited there is a lot to unpack
in this book a lot
and i mean i i zoom through it in a day
oh i think it's just an
incredible read and you saw like we
watch you have watched you on television
for so many years you had smaller roles
starting at the age of six things built
for you you land icarly incredible um
and i loved reading about your
friendship with miranda cosgrove and
oftentimes you wonder like oh do stars
have that kind of relationship when
they're working that closely things are
highly competitive but she was your
emotional support it seems she even went
with you to meet your biological father
for the first time she did
what impact has her friendship had on
your life what does she mean to you oh
my god i love miranda to pieces i always
will she has such a special place in my
heart she helped me
grow as a person and heal as a person
and i hope i did the same for her and i
just love her so much that's wonderful
and i mean of course people come and go
in your in your life throughout your
life in your 20s i feel like a lot that
happens there's a lot of shift and and
and natural kind of growth yeah in your
20s you're finding your footing who you
are do you do you guys still keep in
touch with one another we totally still
keep in touch not as often as we used to
we used to be attached to the hip so it
was very it was very much that kind of
relationship throughout
honestly probably until our mid-20s but
now we're all uh we're all growed up
yeah in our different directions i'm
always rooting for her adulting and she
did speak out on your book has she
reached out to you privately to discuss
some of the the topics in your book the
last i heard from where she said she was
so excited to read it and sent just a
very supportive lovely text about about
reading the book i can't wait for her to
read it i think she'll really like it i
think she'll laugh a lot i think she'll
relate to a lot i'm sure she will i'm
sure she will yeah is there any chance
that acting could be in your future
again i'm shocked to be saying it
shocked myself like when i have you ever
had one of those thoughts where it's
like oh where did that come from why is
this happening um i had that maybe i
want to say a couple months back
where i thought you know what there
might be a way for me to act in it from
a place that feels really healing and
empowered maybe i write something for
myself i don't know what that looks like
i haven't gone that far definitely want
to focus on writing and directing but
i'm open to the idea of acting which
feels like growth to me because i i had
um walked away from it so definitively
in my past which felt important to me at
the time but i'm just at a different
place now it could be like a dark comedy
kind of that's right
but i could see that and i in the book
as well you you talk about how miranda
called you before the reboot yeah icarly
and you said i just can't like basically
no amount of money
no fame or potential like you know come
back for your career
um because you are worried about your
mental health are you happy with that
decision oh my god yeah every decision
that the basis uh one of the main
factors um
that plays into how the the types of
decisions i'm i'm the types of decisions
i make is my mental health yeah and that
comes truly first and foremost for me
and
that's a great thing but i mean with the
reboot your mom your mom's no longer
living right the creator is no longer a
part of the show
so did you just not want to be a part of
the reboot i'm focusing on on what i
choose to focus on you know i'm focusing
on writing and projects that feel
authentic to me and that align with my
mental health